[Music]
kate and aaron are with us in dublin
ohio hi kate aaron how are you guys
hi dave we're doing well good what's up
thank you thank you so much for taking
our call so my brief story i'm a worship
pastor here in ohio i worked at a church
for almost 10 years and then they began
to embrace some
woke resources and ideology so i knew it
was time to move on
the next solid option that god opened
the doors for were me to come down here
to columbus to raise a family at a
different church but we're feeling
pretty discouraged um
the same house
that
uh lived in back home from where we were
up northeast is a hundred thousand
dollars more in this area
we're currently staying in a percentage
rent free with no utilities
we paid off our home before we move down
here
um but we don't want to purchase a home
that is already
we're already outgrowing with the
current state of our family
after yeah if they're just paying off
our house for this so we're essentially
we'd have to get a mortgage for
a minimum a hundred thousand dollars
probably more because of how crazy the
market is here
for the same house we just paid off how
long can you stay in the bar stage
we negotiated yeah we negotiated three
more months when i signed and took on
with this job so three months from today
but i'm sure they would allow us to stay
here a little longer they're pretty
flexible
um i think our concern with that in the
same breath is can we
save quickly enough um as we've noticed
like the mark the market is just
increasing that wasn't why i was asking
got it the reason i was asking was to
give you time to calm down
yeah because you're pretty hyped up
yeah we're exhausted
i can hear it man i mean you're like ah
you're right you're on your last nerve
man
and worship pastors are known for
getting rich i mean they just you guys
make so much money yeah right yeah right
not at all youth pastors worship pastors
is a christian version of starving
people to death but yeah
we love you dave we followed your
principles when we first got married we
paid up all our debt we paid up our
mortgage we've been um investing a
little um we just don't want to destroy
all of that progress i appreciate that
would this be the next option we have we
just had another baby so what is your
household income now
sixty-five thousand okay plus and
uh kate are you working outside the home
with that or you got the babies
yeah no i was but after we had our
second weed shows i chose to stay home
yeah i don't blame you okay
i'll tell you what guys um i want to
help you on this i i and i hear it in
your voice
i'm not making fun of you i'm just i get
it i understand and been there so hang
on kate and aaron are in dublin ohio uh
new job as a worship pastor much more
expensive area than they came from
they're temporarily housed in the
parsonage but only for a few more months
and then they got to make a decision
kate's staying at home with the new
babies aaron's making 65 and a little
bit of a shock to the system when they
got to the more expensive area is that a
fair summary of what you guys told us
very fair what'd you sell your house for
in the other place
205 okay and um you've been trying to
find something comparable closer to the
church reasonably close to the church
anyway and what price range are you
finding there something comparable
well
you said you said 100 extra right so
about didn't you say i would say
yeah 315 320 would be a comparable
parallel move okay got it but asking
they're selling for far beyond that we
saw one house we were interested in go
for 50 000 above asking cash which is
just insane yeah yeah yeah
okay so um here's the thing
uh you're either going you're gonna do
one of two or three things number one i
want you to figure out a way to slow
this process down
because when the more options you have
the more information you have the better
decision you're going to make this feels
very urgent very forced
and i smell a bad decision coming
yeah
does that feel right to you like you're
stressed like you're against the wall
and you're you're backed up and you're
gonna say something later like i was
forced to you weren't really forced you
just put yourself in that corner
yeah okay so i want to slow down so that
might look like renting for a year
okay and just calm just breathe a little
and during that year number one we're
going to learn more about the area than
we know now
which will give you more options
um you're going to discover how far out
you have to drive for the prices to
start dropping
you know there's a point in which the
lines cross between ridiculous commute
and great price
yeah i've got a 15-minute commute so i'm
spoiled
you know but if you went 15 minutes
further than my house the prices dropped
because i'm kind of on the edge of rule
where i am now
you know what i'm saying
and the further you get out in the
country the better the prices are right
right but you know but the but that you
know so you got to find that because you
don't want a two-hour commute
right yeah you know you you but you do
you you do you probably are not going to
be in the back door of this church we
probably already figured that out or
you're going to
spend that year
uh
piling up cash and trying to say we're
gonna take out a fifty thousand dollar
mortgage and not a hundred thousand
and we're gonna bite that bullet and
that's the price we're gonna pay to be
there rather than in in place a rather
than place b
the other thing you're going to be able
to do when you do that is you can slow
down and you don't feel forced into one
of these crazy bidding wars
because you have to choose from what's
on the plate right now you can say
over the next year i'm gonna find
something to sneak up on
okay i'll give you an example of what
happens when you slow down okay this
one's weird this one's weird but this
happened to a friend of mine not long
ago
medium middle middle class price range
house a little bit more than you all are
talking about but in our area it's a
little bit more okay
and uh we've got all these people moving
from other states to tennessee to the
point that to get away from the
craziness and to the point it's almost
like a joke like california
uh refugees in tennessee i mean it's
just it's like a running joke and for
the people moving here it is they're
laughing too but it's like californians
are buying everything you know inside
it's like you can't get a house because
stupid california is buying everything
it's this kind of thing's going on this
is the talk around the water cooler you
know not mad at you people from
california this is what's really going
on so my friend actually you know and
the bidding wars are big time in
nashville it's hard to get a house
big time
my friend actually found a guy who sold
her a house
at below market price right not much
below but just slightly below
so that he didn't have to sell it to
somebody from california
yeah he was worried about voting
he's just like it was a personal thing
you know and and that you know and that
it's funny but you'll find something
where
god god will supply your needs
where there's somebody that says you
know what i might could put this house
up for a bidding war but i'm gonna bless
this young worship pastor
and sell it to him at at appraisal
instead of 50 over appraisal
and you know you'll find that through
someone at the church word of mouth even
through the real estate agent that puts
the word out there that that's what's
going on
and god is not shocked by where you are
he's not surprised
i would add
here's what another year allows you to
do you could put the word out in your
actual church community you don't know
yet maybe you already know that there's
a couple contractors
people that could actually help you
renovate something to where you could
find a jewel
it's not a piece of trash or a death
trap but something that needs some tlc
get it cheaper but it has the square
footage that you need and it turns into
an unbelievable financial gain for you
down the line i mean those are
possibilities i'm not saying that's your
only option but that's something to
consider we're going to get something
like that you pay cash for it what i
want more for you guys than anything is
peace that you don't have right now yeah
right right
and we need it you got little babies
you're you feel like you're a thousand
miles from home and you don't have
enough money and and it's just frenetic
and frantic and anxiety
and um and i don't blame you for being
there but i kind of heard all of that in
your way you were talking earlier
and i'm already hearing a tone change
just by telling you to wait a year i'm
hearing you calm down a little bit
it's true what principles would you say
about renting and any wisdom on that um
some renting properties we've seen here
they're going for 2500 yeah just as
cheap as possible because we're just
buying time
whatever whatever money you spend on
rents buying time that's all it is and
the cheaper you can get
obviously the less you're paying for the
time and the more you can save towards
uh you can add to this pile of savings
you got from the sale of your other
house and so yeah the 2500 doesn't sound
very appealing are there real space
issues in the parsonage
uh some so well
not space just um
more of a i would say an updating and
space for the kids and safety yeah how
long will they let you i mean if you
could talk the minutes letting you stay
there for nine months you know maybe
it's not maybe the magic number's not a
year and the beautiful thing about the
parsonage is you could leave at any time
without breaking a lease if you found
something
right sure
they've been so kind and i'm sure they
would allow us to do that yeah i would
ask for and say listen here's what
here's the council i've been given the
council i've been given is to slow down
and gather more options and more
information
and that feels right to us we'd rather
not move to a rental can
you know if you could suck it up and
live there for free and they'll let you
and still do this extended time a little
bit that's what definitely i would do
that yeah i if there's some safety
issues i'd ask the church to address the
safety issues the kids don't care about
the updating and you guys can put up
with them it's camping it's an adventure
it's a nine-month adventure yeah
yeah it feels like camping for sure i
mean just look at it as you know hey
we're we're gonna do this as an
adventure it's what we're gonna you know
it's the same thing you you know these
people that sell their house and live in
an rv or something it's an adventure
we're gonna do this and so
it's not it's certainly not doing it for
the luxury or something like that
but um
and let the let the timing unfold
uh i love swindoll's saying he says uh
god is never late but seldom early
yeah and so just just give yourself a
little bit of room and let the holy
spirit massage this situation and you in
the process
and um i think this is going to turn out
okay a year from today i really do uh
all of my life experience and my faith
experience points to the fact that it's
gonna turn out okay but it's not gonna
turn out okay if you feel pressured
cornered
uh
anxiety ridden
like you're forced into something and um
you know then you'll go you'll look back
and you go and then god
gave us this house yeah yeah and i i've
i've done that with houses many times
the house i'm living in right now yeah i
feel like it was the same thing i had a
lot of options i
kept moving the options around until i
turned over the right shell and the p
was there you know
but lots of options and lots of
information gives you slow down gives
you better decisions
really good question you guys i'm proud
of you thank you for calling i hope that
helps